ap
[Musique]
es tu
village
des vignes
de lui
et demain
edu
mon village
kalou
drapeau hymne fait
paulette
barcella
le soir aujourd'hui sous du fait non
qu'est ce qu'elle fait on va portes en
ce qu'elle fait tout le monde
c'est comment j'ai mal
[Musique]
ah ah
bah voilà
[Musique]
pauli tu as des chars donc là ta robe
alertés que nous
non mais larcher
[Musique]
simply leur cercle
baisse des
le sam
[Musique]
et les cadeaux reçus
simple
berges de l'aisne
[Musique]
alors même si là le losc romains sont
déjà ici
[Musique]
la flamande
lorsque voilà
passez par là des
[Musique]
bon
pour moi le bivouac marchande va les
folies de la vigne marronne la grotte
[Musique]
on
reçoit les folies de vie voile et la
fille de folie d antoine l'accueillir
mais là dessus
cannes
la vie
obama
et d
qui
mosca
bah
losbar bobette
pintât sida
c'est loupé
mais ce mal an
ses astra
dès lors la
marcelli
mais non ça ne veut l'acheter
[Musique]
bon je t on celle là je la vois grosses
communes comptant
de raki des locaux qui que je vois mon
corps dit si tu es toi vieille toupie
qui nous empêche de jouer
vous n'aurez pas non une pauvre vieille
tout mourante
ça fait 20 ans qu'elle est mourante 20
ans quelle gueule
à chaque fois qu'on joue aux boules de
mauvaises comme la gale avec sa canne si
seulement ça pouvait être vrai qu'elle
est mourante on arrêterait tout de suite
de jouer pour boire la cartagène orange
l'a toujours propriétaire en film on a
soif
maman tu as les assauts dans les petites
watts ont péri
philippe
[Musique]
ses cibles c'est fait
il
neyr argh ce deuxième dimanche de juin
mon cher garçon j'ai attendu tant que
j'ai pu avant de décrire cette chose que
je te demande parce que je sais que tu
étais si content de rester à cette école
où tu dis que tu es si bien quoique je
ne sais pas comment on peut apprendre à
gratter la terre dans une école il n'y a
que les vieux pour enseigner les tours
de main voilà il faut que tu reviennes
si je te dis de revenir c'est bien à
contrecoeur mon petit mais la mauvaise
bêtes nous a gagné deux vitesses
bataille dure pourtant tu peux me croire
mais c'est à se demander si la ligne ne
va pas crever tout uniment j'achève
cette missive pour que ta mère est à
seurre puissent décrire en ce qui les
regarde ton père
roberge auguste ça va sinon pourquoi tu
es 1000 mbps en pensant je suis mis à me
respecte parce que lorsque j'ai mis la
mauvaise bête je n'allais tout de même
pas écrit phylloxéra ce que ça s'écrit
ce mois là est-ce que ça cependant
seulement tu vois pas que ces noms du
diable cécile tu trouves ça naturel pas
bien connaître le [ __ ] qu'il a écrit
ce mot là il a inventé 6 auxerre a tant
manqué d'en masquer
c'est un mot qui porte malheur bande de
sauvages atwan est même voix philippe je
sais pas produire
c'est pourtant la langue bien pendue
embrasse le et de nuit des nouvelles
voies y ait plus de place à
tournefeuille
[Applaudissements]
non je sais pas quoi mettre à
l'effectivité tu es prête pas ici la vie
et blanc planète
la manière est morte hier il a plu ce
fut une fin pacifique popian encore fait
le couillon formé de cuyo maintenant
évidemment transfigure il voulait à tout
prix une mule il a mené la nes les
talons elle en a crevé le curé
l'écoutent auguste elle va pas et créé
toutes ses avances et puis quelle idée
d'envoyer son fils vient le tour de
france des vignes il ya belle lurette
que les compagnons du tour de france ont
disparu mais toi toujours au bout il
faut que tu te distingue peut-être de
faire tu ne venons pas comprendre que
c'est notre dignité notre élévation
quitté sa terre partir librement revenir
après avoir vu des choses ailleurs c'est
un signe ça c'est le signe que nous ne
sommes plus des besogneux des gratteurs
d'arpents nous avons l'honneur d'être
des gens de la terre voilà si tu veux
savoir
ça y est j'ai fini il a plu tout va bien
la vieille magnan est morte et la nes de
popian aussi mille millions de baisers
mon cher philippe cécile ajoute amour
je vais passer à la poste des photos je
m'arrêterai os cassés pour la réunion du
comité de défense
et aux matières grises s'il n'y a pas là
rien officines est passée de la thébaïde
monsieur monsieur lescoutre va nous
faire un bref historique inutile
peut-être pour certains mais
indispensable pour les autres sur
l'invasion de notre région par le
phylloxéra michel mr est il bien temps
de faire d historique
monsieur bahreïn c'est peut-être pour
vous quel historique est le plus
nécessaire
alors si l'historique à faire que ce
soit un vigneron qui les fasse une opa
l'instituteur monsieur l'instituteur n'a
pas de vignes que je sache l'instituteur
monsieur barrel c'est le bésicles qui
donnent la main à charrues c'est
l'alliance du penseur du paysage ll est
l'alliance on vous écoute
avant de commencer je voudrais tout de
même rappeler à monsieur barrel que bien
que ne possédant pas de vignes j'ai été
convoqué il ya deux ans comme tous les
instituteurs et département par la
société d'agriculture de l'hérault pour
apprendre à dépister les premiers signes
du fis observe grédy lalliard avons
mesuré scouts ressasser bien envoyé j'ai
passé mon dimanche à établir ce plan
pour mieux vous expliquer qu'elle fut au
cours des dernières années
là la stratégie si j'ose dire du fils
observe c'est en 1863
voici donc neuf ans qui a paru pour la
première fois ce nouveau parasite sur la
rive droite du rhône dans les terres de
roquemaure et de villeneuve les avignon
l'année suivante traverser le rhône
s'installe et donc sur la rive gauche
atteignant les localités de sorgues et
de châteauneuf du pape
en 66 pénétration dans le nord des
bouches du rhône en 67 à tarascon au
rebond et ramasse en 70 l'ennemi
retraverse le rhône est envahi le
département du gard en 71 l'année
dernière comme vous savez en me
promenant et en furetant dans les vignes
de nairas rgs j'ai eu le triste
privilège de découvrir les hauts de
phylloxéra dans une vigne de monsieur
trop soleil c'était le premier point
d'attac du puceron sur le territoire de
notre commune
c'est pas la peine de me regarder comme
ça c'est pour moi qui les ai pondu ses
oeufs dans mes lignes non tu as pas
pondu les malchances mais quand
l'instituteur arrivée de prévenir tu
aurais dû arracher tout de suite alors
un schéma vers lui enfin juste tu sais
ce que ça représente une ligne
c'est le temps qu'il faut pour le faire
venir
je sais oui seulement ta ligne
aujourd'hui la tâche d'huile en plein
milieu peut-être que la contaminer
toutes les autres villes autour c'est ça
qui me fait peur parce que côté d'eux
m'a paru si la grande vigne à toi la
cour comme oui oui ça me fait peur mais
si demain quelqu'un m'apprend que ma
vigne et malades de la rage tout de
suite sans hésiter je vous lis à tous on
a créé des comités de défense pour
barrer la route aux fléaux de voir à
tous et de voter pour l'arrachage
en tout cas il faut se décider
la commission de l'agriculture sera là
demain
inquisiteur
moi j'arrête la mienne est couillon il
ne s'agit pas de ta vie topiol et va au
perche et dans les garrigues david
gistau pas le phylloxéra cet échec du
maigre jeu larache pour donner l'exemple
puis d'ailleurs elle fait pas de raison
elle me coûte cher et quand il aura
arrachés qu'est ce que tu feras d'un
couillon en fout oui c'est vrai des
cours et alors qu'ils tirent à pêcher la
led avec une poêle à frire parce qu'il
est une aile essayons de revenir à la
question je vous en prie messieurs les
scouts votre ami je crois que la seule
solution est effectivement d'arracher
les huit malades suisse qu'outre une
vigne c'est aussi sacrée que la personne
humaine parfaitement
c'est une espèce de personnalités la
vigne les ouvriers j'arrache essai pour
sauver les autres me dit don est ce que
j'ai une gueule à sauver les autres bd
ben voyons alphonse c'est une commission
de savants qui vient demain il faut
faire la part du feu
le premier point d'invasion et chez toi
à notre faute
moi je rachetais aligné pour la pétoire
de toute façon ça m'est égal je vais
faire facteurs écoute moi bien trop crié
'toi des vignes comme là-bas russe y en
a partout et plus belle encore dans les
terres basses du côté de l'état pour moi
la couronne c'est ma meilleure venir je
les crée j'ai fabriqué moi même avec ses
malles à elle et mon enfant mais je te
jure que si demain le phylloxéra sim et
arrache tout de suite on va pas laisser
détruire toute la région pour arrêter le
fléau je refuse
pendant neuf ans le regarder le mal se
répandent jusqu'ici et maintenant c'est
moi qui draine chaque défilé non et non
chacun se débrouille
je garde ma vigne et je démissionne de
votre comité de défense
[Musique]
un vieux filets bonjour calixte
alors tu es revenu eh ouais
cécile cécile regarde qui nous arrive
[Musique]
mais comme tu est pâle oblong thomas pas
le sien tu as maigri ils montent à
mourir si tu savais comme si content qu
est ce que tu as grandi
cécile j'ouvre des bouteilles de
carthagène gêner on vient voir la
cartagène le retour d'un grand voyageur
ça se fête
tout le monde pense dans le visage que
j'ai eu tort que je me suis affolé en
faisant revenir et personne ne sait
exactement pourquoi il va comprendre ce
qui va décider bien entendu tu ne dis
rien ta mère elle a jamais été aussi
belle que cette année à temps
[Applaudissements]
voilà
à
[Applaudissements]
regarde
il n'y a pas besoin de la loupe de mai
chez les maîtres d'école la tête et
peignez juillet pourri
il y aura cette année une belle récolte
la cour reconnaît fini maintenant je
prochaine elle sera toute tâche est en
fait pas part à notre vie mais on en a
vu d'autres on arrivera bien la guérir
donc cette fois ci je ne crois pas
[Applaudissements]
ce
si si
les parasites attaqué la vigne par le
haut la tête par la feuille par la
grappe dans la région là je travaille
dans la racine cette vague souterraines
et la vilaine affaire le mauvais sort
jeté aux raisins la terre comme si on
emprisonne élevé d'un nourrisson en
trouvant rien tu verras
[Applaudissements]
c'est comment ça s'appelle une france à
un crime de la nature et la nature en
état de clichés martel
on va voir les autres nuits on nous a
plusieurs jours que la cheminée tir man
auguste c'est encore les briques diot
qui ont bougé
il faut qu'une bande à julien devenu lui
mettre un petit mot je viens j'ai vu
quand je suis arrivé avec coupions bien
c'est à couillon moi te dit ça est
gentil ce maniaque serra couillaud les
lunel et tous fait d'une alice fait des
clients barbey philippe montpellier dans
le début j'étais assis en face dans
gendarmes de lunel du c'est ce qui m'a
dit que tout ce n'est rare c'était des
couilles aux gendarmes ils bien répondu
oui j'étais sans doute vrai vu que je
connaissais cette gare de nérac et est
devenu gendarme père gendarme se moquer
d'un gendarme
il a bien fait ah oui alors bon c'est si
tu nous donnes libres de réseaux étoilé
de regarder ton frère et que s'intéresse
l'un bouzid
il faut bien des d'état mr
à voir les comptes
elles n'ont jamais été aussi bons que
cette année et ligne d'art allemands
sont en pleine force a eu raison de
replanter la fontaine royal il ya cinq
ans ici c'est qu'on a le noir et le
carignan 4 foudre plaza ras bord ainsi
le vase devons bien ça va être une belle
année
et puis les vendanges s'annoncent belles
on n'a pas eu de grêle a gelé la pluie
quand il le fallait et beaucoup de
soleil
c'est bien de bains va faire un bon
degré 1 ça va être une belle année où
des plus belles années qu'on ait jamais
eu
et peut-être la dernière cette saloperie
de philo c'est alors qu'est ce que tu as
pris là où dans ton école en champagne
un peu tout la vie des végétaux de
calcul leur comptage de taille des
arbres taille des arbres et pour quoi
faire
les arbres ici à la papa la plus c'est
dommage dommage elle rouvre d'amaury en
bas de la cour comme si j'avais pas
arracher les cinq ou six à s'y trouver
j'aurais jamais pu alourdir la ville
comme angers pas sûrs les gens qui
l'entendront fille facile alors c'est sa
bande appris à l'école pratique il ya
des rats son père qui n'a pas eu raison
mais pas en colère
pareil à ton père philippe
peut-être qu'il appelle réseau mais il a
très bien fait alors toi aussi pas aussi
tu trouves que j'ai pas eu raison ces
conditions quel maître ici entre
ressources
le pape a encore une chance sinon tu vas
dans mon école ya une chose comment
enseigner une chose que je n'oublierai
jamais
tiens un arbre qui pousse quelqu'un sait
que cet arbre est nécessaire et les
oiseaux qui viennent sur cet arbre son
nid d'oiseau nécessaire les oiseaux aux
bouffes les insectes
bon on a trouvé un sac j'ai suffisamment
bien n'est pas trop tu coupent les
arbres les oiseaux s'en vont et alors il
ya trop d'insectes tu vois pas dans la
nature chaque chose à sa place chaque
chose à sa raison d'être et en supprime
une c'est comme si on enlevait la grosse
faute de la magnanerie tout s'écroule
peut-être bien que sur les parachutes ou
césar pour agrandir les vignes on
n'aurait pas eu la cote chili c'est la
pire année de phylloxéra
oui
tu vas pas d'autres
[Musique]
c'est la paille
on veut des nids de poule ou pépé et
c'est révélateur
[Applaudissements]
noreen leur hymne quoi déjà
bon
allez viens avec moi d'accord mais
pourquoi tu veux pas tout seul j'ose pas
si je mets tout seul et vaincre hors jeu
ne cherchons ni de situer avec moi on se
promène en rencontrera pas bon jusqu'ici
j'ai bien compris maintenant reste à
savoir à temps pour voir plus clair rien
ou un dessin au tableau noir
bon voilà voici le sol
et voici une souche donc tu plonges
d'attiches creuse comme ça en diagonale
mais ça et comme les yeux de phylloxéra
sont très profonds il faut qu'à paille
la tige que tu as rempli mixture l'ordre
et décembre jusqu'au lundi seuls biens
et ensuite ensuite une bonne averse de
pluie il entraîne la mixture promet un
petit conduit jusqu'aux os de phylloxéra
est une bonne idée
reste à savoir quelles sont les vertus
effective des tas mixture tout ce que je
sais ce qu elle est radicale contre les
parasites potager j'ai vu expérimenté
plusieurs fois l'école de l'agriculture
après tout pourquoi ne pas essayer
moi j'ai confiance en toi philippe
l'essentiel c'est de lutter
bonjour bonjour fini
ce
ski
à sous
que tu fais là
ce
garde
de plus en tant qu tellement que ceux
qui ont même pas tourner de leur fait et
souche je soigne enfin je sais france
comment ça
ce
assieds toi
c'est une expérience que je fais
répondit de la mixture ou quelqu'un sous
la pluie la fra a pénétré dans le sol
pleuvra c'est pas maintenant ce sera
après les vendanges mais il pleuvra
bon maintenant je vais m'occuper du
cheval écoute polie ne sais pas qui me
plaisent pas mais ce que j'aime pas chez
toi pauline c'est que tu te conduis pas
comme une fille attend pas qu'on me
demande ce qu'ils demandent on s'est dit
c'est pas ça il ya deux ans quand son
cousin tué par balles à ton père
bonjour surtout ceux liés à l'or il ya
ça mon père m'a dit que la pauvre femme
était morte et wi fi nissent alors
philippe il paraît que tu as trouvé un
remède contre la mauvaise vie où vous
auriez trouvé du tout ce que des essais
tout le monde fait des essais partout
l'essentiel c'est de tenir le coup et
surtout de ne pas se résoudre à arracher
les lignes allaient enfin bon soir
ce
voilà voilà en tout cas ce qui certain
mon ami c'est que l'ordre moral vote et
respect l'ordre moral sculptures et il
suffit pas d'en parler
votre devoir c'est de l'imposer tenez
écoutez les il rit il jure il blasphème
et les filles 1 essayez les fans
sculpture et le soir venu
elles se retrouvent toutes les cuisses
en l'air comme des bêtes monsieur le
curé comme des bêtes
ah ah il est beau leur moral vous parlez
comme mac mahon ma bonne mais il faut
être un peu indulgents
alors monsieur le curé vous avez envie
de vous faire tuer pointe couillon c'est
un point quand tu peux être dur et que
tu dire c'est bien parce qu'à lui il
vient de jouer comme si tu étais de type
de dérapage c'est le treizième au pian
confiant tiens on m'a donné cette lettre
pour toi ça vient de montpellier et du
louvre
c'est ma convocation
pour passer mon concours de facteur la
convocation
ça s'arrose mais attendez que je sois
reçues mieux que deux tu l'auras en film
[Applaudissements]
au film il ya poupille en mai qu'il peut
y avoir dans le cas où l'usap a reçus
les habitants boivent tout de suite
ça va me porter malchance quoi de payer
à boire avant mon concours bon mais non
je suis le fils et de voir inverse faut
qu'ils payent je travaille aussi là il
faut toujours qu'ils s'occupent bon vous
venez à la maison
et bien d'après une démarche facteurs je
prends une démarche de facteurs sais
comment c'est une démarche de
factionnelle a factor ça marche comme ça
regarde chaque année 2009 le pape a
raison et déraison pure la raison c'est
quoi les amusements c'est un bébé ont
fermé ce soir à jour
philippe tu m'accompagnes demain à la
foire comporte à lunel oui on parle
matin par dix
bon je vais faire un tour soit bonsoir
le bon tour sur le toit ouais pas avoir
été garde moi celle là cette béatitude
si tu retournes à ta vaisselle j'ai fini
on va te coucher
hier mon choix bonsoir il
tu sais en déficit
ça fait 15 jours que tous les soirs il
va le faire ce tout le mois alors voila
j'aimerais bien savoir avec qui le fait
c'est tout des fois que ce serait avec
pauline trousselier non c'est pas avec
la police est de savoir où gates a
rassuré
eh bien ma cécile est joli métier que tu
ne devais faire
[Applaudissements]
je
mes compliments monsieur jardinier un
jardin que j'ai volontairement
abandonnés parce que ça ne valait pas la
peine de gâcher travailliste signé pour
une terre sèche comme une peau de
tambour et toi sont seulement vu
demander la permission tu vas tu vas le
travail et au clair de lune ça fait
envie d'un jardin on et finiront on n'a
pas de temps à perdre pour un jardin j'y
suis retourné ce matin le soleil soleil
cécile cécile il ya fait du propre
monsieur ton fils il y avait plein de
vieux arbres
monsieur non seulement les ateliers
embellie et la guerre mais les à fumer
avec 8 e reichstett maligne il a fumé
les arbres départ des télés figues et
les premiers il a tout tué
et puis la lignée des rangées de thomas
des rangées de service et 86,6 parce que
ça c'est le fin du fin il a greffé des
aubergines sur des pieds de tomates mais
pas peur c'est pareil ainsi et alors
c'est vrai qu'on prend et fort la terre
ne se cultive pas quand les poules sont
sur le perchoir
on travaille le jour on travaille la
vigne quand on a fini on se lave on se
change et on va sur la place il ferait
mieux de jouer de la trompette ou
d'aller voir les filles voilà quand
j'avais tournage et enfin cécile des
aubergines sur des pieds de tomates
si je me sers pas ton fumier si je le
travaille le jour après la vigne
tu me laisses jardin oum effectué le
promet de jouer de la trompette d'aller
voir les filles
[Applaudissements]
non
pourtant alors pour bien
un facteur fille
tant qu'on court
je joue
qui se fient dépayse ne t'en fais pas ma
paupière on est aussi heureux paysans
que facteur
d'autres labos village tous deux mois
maintenant ça fait tellement prise de
parts risque personnes rigolera
allez viens avec moi je vais te montrer
mon jardin jeune greffé sur des tiges de
navets des plantes sous cabut toi aussi
tu me racontes défense
mais non bien voir
[Applaudissements]
voilà on verra bien ce que ça fera
peut-être que ça donnera un résultat
pourquoi
boffo monde est fou c'est bien il pas
très bien à séparer ce qui est possible
ce qui est pas possible
comme si j'avais besoin de lunettes à
l'intérieur de la tête alors je suis
méfiant
tu vois sur ses sommets par ici
j'avais une ville d'hommes
préhistoriques
non ce qu'il faisait là quand on cherche
dans les cailloux troupe des grattoirs
de fléchettes d'avoir dans le bon soin
de la terre nous partout par ici il n'ya
pas si longtemps c'est vrai pas un peu
de mots crus années philippe et avec
quoi il aurait monté jusqu ici l'eau
c'est plus c'est que l'enfer ici il y
avait de l'eau partout écoutes dont ces
noms de garrigue par ici fombonne
aquavit à couler douce
mont royal avec bell rien que des noms
de sources
[Musique]
au clip je suis vaudra les stocks à
nouveau
oui je te dérange mais non monsieur le
maire alors qu'est ce qu'apporte en
service encore besoin de vendangeurs
août est complet ah non j'ai besoin de
personne
j'aimais cévenol qui arrive demain et
puis je viens d'engager époux pierre
antoine juliens noreen tout abandonner
c'était pour ce citoyen oui tu es
montagne r non alors ça tombe mal parce
que moi pour les vendanges quand je
prends des étrangers je choisis que des
montagnards sont les plus robustes et
les rois fainéants
je suis pas un feignant que je prends
d'étrangers d'emblée auguste à partir
d'aujourd'hui c'est un ra en bois et un
propriétaire
c'est le petit neveu de la peau
victorine tu es mort qui est de moi j'ai
une petite nouvelle victorine celui
d'argelès
oui mais on castagnet alors si tu es
d'argeliers s est situé de l'aude
tu fais pas un fainéant je t'engage
merci
dites moi monsieur robert je voulais
vous dire ma tante m'a laissé sa maison
et ses quatre ving j'ai compris tu
vendanges pour moi je te paie pas et en
échange je t'aide à vendanger t ligne
c'est bien ça c'est ça allez on va voir
[Musique]
no more heroes
la teneur
marino au plat ghana
quelques semaines elle s'est faite la
petite marie depuis lundi donc la
chambre de l'écurie du virus dans celles
oubliées un raisin j'en connais un qui
se fera un plaisir de la mousse tnt vous
m'aiderez jamais fait et l'outrance el
kalaï est aussi gros
à g est où vas-tu tenuta la dir est au
big roar des trois cités nous gardent un
imam a aimé boli mari arrivent et on
anime à mike & molly marisa lire ça se
travaille à la grèce
coli ou nommer sa chaîne travaille à
baillestavy aux fruits égal ou la
tablette ailleurs rio et sega ou là
iranienne
[Musique]
marie d'avoir j'ai quelque chose à te
montrer
[Musique]
[Rires]
bakou
non
c'est fait
mais vu
mon village
d
dans les
et m
edu
[Musique]
allo
dorado kim fait
moritz
batasuna
[Musique]
espace
mais la neige
c'est demain soir
des roms
espace
l'aspect
[Musique]
oh
es tu
[Musique]
mais là j'ai
c'est pelé
les recettes
baisse des
lessard
eric holder
ses clips
ben c'est que leno
[Musique]
beauvais
pintât c'est la lose
l'autre homme la sauce
mais ça ici
[Musique]
la flamande
dans ce cas là
passez par là
oh
[Musique]